hello and i have a book coming out we're
so excited we've been working on it we
wrote it together we photographed it
together we threw it together yes we did
i know i just lost 15 pounds i'm super
proud
[Applause]
making our cookbook and you know covet
all of it you know anyway what are your
five favorite ingredients to cook with
look for and shop this fall okay um
first thing to go is really the spices i
go to the spice cabinet first and that's
what starts to change pilar loves spice
spice and flavor bringing an element of
surprise is a huge part of our cookbook
just a little twist here and there on
recipes that bring an element where
you're like oh that's unique unexpected
yeah right so for fall we turn to these
warm spices think like cinnamon ginger
star anise cloves so those are really
going to start like warming things up in
the kitchen the second favorite fall
ingredient is the apple quintessential
fall ingredient right next up we have
fennel which i love fennel it's my
beloved vegetable
it's really wonderful in salads like
shaved raw but you can actually also
roast it and it just starts to get like
super gooey and caramely and it has like
this sweet licorice taste next up grapes
again you know people eat it raw like as
a snack i really love them cooked and i
love them pickled so this is something
that you can experiment you can pickle
them in balsamic vinegar some of those
warm spices they're it's really really
delicious okay i know you so well but i
have to admit i wasn't even expecting
you to pickle a grape and include
stomach in balsamic and warm spices
knock yourself out and the last
ingredient
we have is the squash they come in all
shapes and sizes there are fall
workhorse ingredients they deliver so we
are making a roast stuffed delicata
squash roast and stuff yes with a maple
rosemary dressing so i mean it's fall
let's go so the first thing i love it
we only had one person maybe
before
all right the first thing hopefully
we'll get a little more all right let's
the first thing we're going to do is
actually make the dressing in the bowl
beside you to your aha there you go got
it um and here we have two tablespoons
of maple syrup
i'm gonna dump that in the bowl and to
that we're gonna add one tablespoon
chopped rosemary
and then to amp it up we're gonna do the
three tablespoons of balsamic
and one tablespoon of miso paste i love
miso paste yeah so you're gonna whisk
that in basically until you get it all
in the same consistency and drizzle in a
little bit of olive oil
okay so this sauce is actually gonna
double duty the first thing we're gonna
do is put your d seeded and have
delicota squash
in that mixture you're gonna toss it
around give it a good coat so we're
basically amping up the flavor okay
double duty so you also have a cup of
grapes so we're going to put the grapes
on there as well we're going to roast
the grapes
oh oh that's so pretty
okay so we're going to walk these over
actually um
and they're going to roast at a 400
degree oven 400 degrees 35 minutes 35
minutes until fully tender until tender
and cooked through and cooked through
thank you i love the interior of this
oven every time i open it it sparks so
beautiful right oh it's that like okay
electric i'm gonna grab you for a second
hot pan pull it out of the oven hot pan
my dear
hot hot hot
all right
beautiful gosh this it smells so good
already this really has the most
beautiful aroma
of squash it's really present and then
in your saucepan we've been cooking a
little bacon and shallots and then to
the pan drew you're gonna add
we have here two and a half cups of
black rice two and a half cups rice and
then we're going to add the rest of that
dressing into that black rice because we
don't want any of that good stuff the
maple the balsamic to go to waste
lovely lovely lovely
give that a good stir
stirring so we're adding some raw celery
to this
really yes
[Music]
and then some pepitas you can use any
toasted nuts or seeds that you want as
well like a walnut absolutely a walnut i
think would be really nice or a hazelnut
that sort of thing and then the last
thing drew is just the arugula you want
to add the arugula at the end when it'll
wilt too much exactly right you want to
turn off the heat add the arugula give
it a good mix got it
feel like i'm done you get into bed
there you go get in that bed it's
actually really delicious as is right
now but what we're gonna do
to make it a little fancy and full like
we're gonna stuff those with some of the
roasted grapes too
into
your squash
okay mine's i'm you know how you doing
well i represent the person who isn't
perfect
so
you know
i think you're doing really great it
looks good i'm the person who's doing
the you know
more fun haphazard approach
um because then kind of how i live my
life
all right okay uh four shall we
right in there okay and i'm just gonna
oh wow it's like butter yeah
it's my thing
cheers cheers
whoa
[Applause]
thank you so much
head to the drewberrymarshow.com for
this recipe and you can also get more
yummy recipes from me and pilar in our
upcoming book rebel homemaker coming out
november 2nd because you know i'm a
rebel and a homemaker and you're the
amazing chef and we made it together
[Music]
you